The neoliberal Establishment has decided
it can't win arguments
nobody wants what they're selling at all
so why even bother to convince anybody
so instead they're going right to force
and you're seeing that all over our
country and one of the ways they're
inflicting for some people inflicting
pain is through civil suits bring them
to civil court because anyone can file a
lawsuit and so a lot of well-funded
lawsuits trying to shut people up or
punish them for stepping out of line and
here's the latest example this has not
gotten enough coverage so Tara Reid once
worked for Joe Biden he sexually
assaulted her and she made possibly the
mistake of saying so out loud you're not
allowed to do that so in retaliation
against her the New York Times posted
her social security number on her
website can you imagine the
ramifications of that so Tara Reid sued
the New York Times because you can't put
people's Social Security numbers on a
website
but a federal judge has now ruled
Against Terror Reed and said that she
has to pay the legal fees of the New
York Times so they're still trying to
crush her and we think it's wrong she
joins us now thanks so much for coming
on did I mistake any of that I mean it
seems like you came out and accused the
sitting president of a sex crime and
we've spoken a great length about this
on the air and I don't think there's any
question that had happened you said so
at the time
and now they're trying to hurt you for
saying that that's what it looks like to
me
um yes this is just one of the many
things that they've done you know to try
to silence me
um but yeah the um lawsuit that I filed
was because on the first story that they
did the New York Times and you know they
used me as a basically a whipping post
all of 2020 to try to silence and
discredit me but the first story was on
Easter Sunday and I was woken up very
early in the morning by a friend who
lived back east and said hey the online
story on New York Times how's your your
Congressional ID showing your social
security number we need to get it down
it took a few hours we got it down and
um they did comply with taking it down
but it was very it was very awful so I
did try to file a lawsuit I lost the
judge ruled that it was in the public
interest to print it and um I then was
slapped with attorneys fees from New
York Times upwards close to over seventy
one thousand dollars so
so you are not a rich person I know from
our conversations
um so just two quick questions how is it
in the Public's interest for the New
York Times to publish your social
security number of all of all private
things
well suddenly I guess there was a great
interest in freedom of speech so in
freedom of the press so freedom of the
press would be the impetus for that
um and and sort of a more of a legal
argument and I don't want to bore your
audience with all of that but there's
been different ways um that the uh you
know Biden Administration has come after
me they've come after me with the doj
with sealed warrants on my Twitter which
are of record and had there's been uh
you know a little bit of press about
that they took my you know
Communications on Twitter and all of
that so yeah it's been
um you know watching Joe Biden take a
wrecking ball to my I've been
experiencing this wrecking ball to my
life but now I've been watching the last
couple of years taking wrecking ball to
the United States including you know the
proxy war that Russia and uh NATO that
that NATO is and U.S is fighting against
Russia you know and upwards of 100
billion dollars going over there when we
have dire circumstances here so all of
those things that I talked about that I
criticized um Joe Biden about besides
the awful experience of being sexually
assaulted by him when I was a senate
staffer in 1993.
um you know our
people are seeing just the true Joe
Biden of how corrupt this regime is and
if there needs to be any regime change
it doesn't need to be in other countries
it needs to happen here now I agree so I
agree we're seeing how cruel and
ruthless they are and not only they they
don't believe all women they will hurt
women who disobey and you're perfect and
further Tucker you know the New York
Times has become the Legacy Media has
become like an arm of the Biden
Administration like the doj and the FBI
I mean look at what just happened to
Matt taibi who testified about you know
the different ways that they're trying
to suppress U.S citizen speech and using
taxpayer money to do it and control the
conversation and control the narrative
he got visited by an IRS agent the day
of his testimony so they sent the IRS to
your house
I'm not so we're all waiting for that
and I know that you are well you're
living in now Terry thank you so much
for coming on appreciate it thank you
for having me I appreciate it subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight